researchers at Vanderbilt University
developed an app that analyzes
shockwaves from bullets to determine the
location of snipers and a Belgian
designer has created smart polymer
furniture that's self assembling and
grows like popcorn Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow sewing is an
artificial brain that can now use the
internet to learn new things developed
at the Tokyo Institute of Technology the
machine learning algorithm can learn
about objects using image searches it
also has the ability to take aspects of
other objects and combine them to make
guesses about things that it doesn't
recognize by storing characteristics of
objects like pens and knives being stick
shaped it can then further differentiate
them and determine for instance what a
box cutter is and it can pick out
features from audio and video data and
the system is in development for
autonomous mental development robots I
guess this is a mate Iike Intel and
Carnegie Mellon University are creating
headlights that make raindrops disappear
each headlight is actually a projector
instead of a lamp and has a camera which
picks up the raindrops and that a
processor predicts their paths darkens
those pixels and making the raindrops
invisible but unfortunately they say
this technology probably won't be
commercially available for a decade
triangle tree has created edible spoons
with disposable plastic spoons taking
more than 20 years to decompose this
eco-friendly alternative is made from
all organic ingredients and comes in
three flavors
it also features weakened lines on the
back of the edible spoon so it's easier
to break off and eat ultimate Bloody
Mary woolen prints are making wool
button-down shirts that last six times
longer than cotton are naturally anti
wrinkle and odor fighting founder Mac
Bishop demonstrated the longevity of the
fine grade wool fabric by wearing the
same shirt for a hundred days straight
without washing it for more information
find the link below
this bright green robot mecha-suit was
built by Japanese robotics company
Sakakibara ki Kai it's called the kids
Walker Cyclops and comes equipped with
one arm for grabbing and the other has a
drill it's about six feet nine inches
tall and about three feet six inches
wide and weighs 750 pounds it cost
twenty thousand five hundred dollars to
own but is available to rent this robot
can tell what humans are so it doesn't
crush them roboticists from Georgia Tech
in San francisco-based mecha robots
built a robot armed with sensitive skin
giving it the ability to reach through
cluttered areas carefully as well as
gently touch a human shown here lifting
a blanket from a disabled man who says
that the arm never pressed hard against
him and he felt safe using it finally
like spin by Erik Perrin timecode lab
has dancers illuminated combining bullet
time photography stop-motion and light
painting
I'm gonna leave you with a laser
shooting through 100 balloons and as
always thanks for watching